so that we don't get stumped by the
arbeiglas in our life and especially
when we don't have talking words to help
us
we should be able to identify when
things get a little bit weird with our
systems of equations when we have
scenarios that have an infinite number
of solutions or that have no solutions
at all and just as a little bit of a
review of what could happen
these are the think about the three
scenarios you have the first scenario
which is kind of where we started off
where you have two systems that just
intersect in one place and then you have
essentially one solution so if you were
to graphically represent it you have one
solution right over there one
one solution
and this means that the two constraints
are consistent
consistent
and the two constraints are independent
of each other they're not the exact same
line
consistent
independent
consistent and independent then you have
the other scenario
you have the other scenario
where
they're consistent they intersect but
they're essentially the same line they
intersect everywhere so this is one of
the constraints or one of the equations
or the other one if you look at it if
you graph it it's actually the exact
same one
so here you have an infinite number
infinite number of solutions it's
consistent
it's consistent you do have solutions
here but they're dependent equations
it's a dependent system
dependent
and then the last scenario and this is
when you're dealing in two dimensions
the last scenario are is where your two
constraints just don't intersect with
each other one might look like this and
then the other might look like
this they have the exact same slope but
they have different intercepts so this
there is no solution
no solution they never intersect
and we call this an inconsistent system
in
consistent and if you wanted to think
about what would happen just think about
what's going on here
here you have different slopes
here they have different slopes
different slopes and if you think about
it two different lines with different
slopes are definitely going to intersect
in exactly one place
in exactly one place here they have the
same slope and same y-intercept same
same slope and same y-intercepts you
have an infinite number of solutions
here you have the same slope
same
slope but different y-intercepts and you
get no solutions so the times when
you're solving systems where things are
going to get a little bit weird are
where you have the same
as when you have the same slope
and if you think about it what defines
the slope and i encourage you to test
this out with different equations is
when you have if you have your x's and
y's or you have your a's and b's or you
have your variables on say on the same
side of an equation
where they have the same ratio with
respect to each other so with that kind
of keeping that in mind let's see if we
can if we can think about what types of
solutions we might find
so let's take this down so they say
determine how many solutions exist for
the systems of equi system of equations
so you have 10x minus 2y is equal to 4
and 10x minus 2y is equal to 16.
so just based on what we just talked
about the x and the x's and the y's are
on the same side of the equation and the
ratio is 10 to negative 2 10 to negative
2 same ratio so something strange is
going to happen here but when we have
the same kind of combination of x's and
y's in the first one we get 4 and on the
second one we get 16. so that seems a
little bit bizarre another way to think
about we have the same number of x's the
same number of y's but we got the same a
different number on the right hand side
so if you were to simplify this and we
could even look at the hints to see what
it says you'll see that you're going to
end up with the same slope but different
y-intercepts
so we convert both the slope intercept
form
right over here and you see one the blue
one is y is equal to five x minus two
and the green one is y is equal to five
x minus eight same slope same ratio
between the x's and the y's
but but you have different values right
over here you have different different
y-intercepts so here you have no
solutions
no solutions that is
that is this scenario right over here if
you were to graph it
so no solutions check our answer
let's go to the next question
so let's look at this one right over
here
so we have negative 5 times x and
negative 1 times y
we have 4 times x and 1 times y so it
looks like the ratio if then we're
looking at the x's and y is always on
the left-hand side right over here it
looks like the ratios of x's y's are
different you have essentially five x's
for every one y you could say negative
five x's for every negative one y and
here you have four x's for every one y
so this is fundamentally a different
ratio so right off the bat you could say
well these are going to intersect in
exactly one place if you were to put
this into slope-intercept form you will
see that they have different slopes so
you can say this has one solution and
you can check your answer and you can
look at the solution just to verify
so and i encourage you to do this so you
see the blue one if you put in the slope
intercept form negative 5x plus 10
and you take the green one into
slope-intercept form negative 4x minus
8. so different slopes they're
definitely going to intersect in exactly
one place you're going to have one
solution let's try another one
so here we have 2x plus y is equal to
negative 3 and this is pretty clear you
have 2x plus y is equal to negative 3.
these are the exact same equations so
it's consistent information there's
definitely solutions but there's an
infinite number of solutions right over
here these are this is a dependent
system
so there are infinite number of
solutions here and we can check our
answer let's do one more because that
was a little bit too easy okay so this
is interesting right over here we have
it in different forms
2x plus y is equal to negative 4 y is
equal to negative 2x minus 4. so let's
take this first blue equation let's take
this blue equation and put it into
slope-intercept form if we did that you
would get if you just subtract 2x from
both sides you get y is equal to
negative 2x minus 4 which is the exact
same thing as this equation right over
here so once again they're the exact
same equation you have an infinite
number of solutions check our answer and
you can look at the solution right here
you convert the blue into slope
intercept you get the exact same thing
as what you saw in the green one